hello everyone my name is ivan and
i wish you a very warm welcome to this
presentation
of multi-omics data analysis in part
tech flow
what am i going to talk about today
first just a brief overview of
bartek flow our software package for
multiomics
then i will give a live demo of analysis
of two data sets
the first one is tissue transcriptomics
that is
integration of transcriptomics and
histology
the second one is excite seek
integration of crispr
proteomics and transcriptomics
when creating particle flow we have
different types of users in mind
biologists bioinformaticians and large
organizations
and we included a wide range of
functionalities to meet their respective
requirements
with part tech flow there is no need for
command line or knowledge of a
programming language
all the analysis are performed using
point and click interface
in addition to our own algorithms
particle
ships with a number of commonly used
tools and you can also add your own
tools
or scripts to visualize your
data you can choose between many plots
available in partic flow
finally particle includes user and data
management as well as the resource
management tools
here's just a small example of our
charts
all the plots can be extensively
modified and then downloaded to your
local computer
as an image file
partak flow is compatible with all major
single cell platforms
some of which are shown here on the
slide
in terms of essays we support a wide
range of omics
essays genomics and proteomics alike
you can analyze your data in bartek flow
from start to finish
to begin with you can import your bcl
files
your fastq files or your account matrix
files
in addition we support sera objects
following import you can proceed to any
downstream steps for example
perform qc batch correction
interact with the data perform path
analysis
perform differential gene or protein
expression
and perform clustering analysis in the
interest of time
i will now introduce you to the first
data set
the data that i am using is public
released by 10x genomics
briefly fresh frozen mouse tissue was
processed
adhering to the vision spatial protocol
and the brains were cut
into 10 micrometer thick sagittal slices
the section that i will show in my demo
and you see it on the screen
consists of approximately 3 300 tissue
spots which were then sequenced
the idea is to analyze gene expression
of those tissue spots
and integrate with histology data
during the demo i am going to focus on
cerebellum
which is right here in the top left
quadrant
cerebellar cortex consists of three
tissue layers
starting from the surface that is the
thick molecular layer
then a very thin parking layer and
finally the deepest one
granular layer deeper than that is the
cerebellar white matter
now each of the cerebral layers is built
of different types of cells
and the question is can we identify the
gene expression signatures of those cell
types
the answer is yes i identified the
cerebellar cell types using particle
and i am now going to switch to live
demo and show you how i did
it this is part tech flow and we are
looking at the data viewer
our visualization and analysis tool
the dots that you see on the plot are
tissue spots
by decreasing the dot opacity i will
shift from transcriptomics to histology
and back
let me open the controls here we go
changing the opacity now we see
histology
and back to transcriptomics
what about these colors they indicate
cell types that i identified based on
the transcription profiles
we can see the inhibitory and purkinje
cells as the red dots
next in blue are king cells
after that yellow dots which represent
the granule cells
finally there are some green dots their
gene expression signature
is consistent with oligodendrocytes and
we see them in the white matter of the
cerebellum but also in other brain
regions
i'm sure you will agree this is a
perfect match between transcriptome
information and histology data
let me now take you over key steps i
started with exploratory analysis
and to get the best insight into the
data i
invoked three different plots in
parallel pca on the left
tsn in the middle and umap on the right
the dots are tissue spots upstream of
this visualization i involve graph-based
clustering and the clusters
are shown by colors by default
our plots are shown in 3d and they're
fully interactive
you can rotate them
zoom in zoom out and
literally focus on individual data
points
for this analysis i prefer the disney
visualization
therefore i'm going to close the other
two charts
and reset the disney view my task here
is to identify the clusters
and learn about the cells within each
cluster i can either look at a global
plot like this one
or focus on one cluster at a time in the
other words
split the plot by cluster let's do that
the controls are here on the left
first we are going to take a look at the
data card
which is the summary of my analysis
steps
you can tell that i started with a
quantified matrix
then i fill filter the barcodes i filter
genes i normalize the expression values
and finally rp by perform clustering
clicking on the clustering result node
shows me the available
attributes here we go clustering result
drag
and drop on the chart to split the plot
by
here we go one subplot
per cluster they are all connected
if i rotate one the others will follow
i prefer to customize this chart by
slightly decreasing the dot size
like this now whenever you perform
clustering
and we support a number of clustering
tools such as graph-based clustering
k-means clustering or hierarchical
clustering
article produces a table with cluster
biomarkers
and i will now add a table to the data
viewer
adding a table is easy i start with the
clustering result
dragged to the main window where do i
want to put it
just at the bottom and i'm adding
a table
here it is my biomarker table with gene
specific for each cluster
i will resize slightly
now let's take a look at cluster number
seven for example
the top gene or the most significant
marker for cluster 7
is a gene called protein phosphatase 1 a
regulatory subunit 17
or simply 1r17
the table is connected to the plot and
to
examine the expression levels of ppp1
r17
across my tissue spots i just grab the
gene
and drag to the disney color by here we
go
okay let me show the legend
it goes from green to red
tissue spots with no expression of this
gene
are in green and the redder spot is the
higher is the expression of ppp1r17
the reason why i decided to focus on
this gene is that it's expressed by
purkinje cells
purkinje cells are neurons and they can
be found in the cerebellum
looking at the spot clusters
we see high expression levels of this
gene in cluster number seven
but we also see some positive spots in
clusters 9
and cluster 12. having seen this
i want to know more about the
relationship between clusters 7
9 and 12. therefore i'm going to
merge the subplots
here we go split by
none perhaps customize the dot size
again this time i'm going to
increase it like this
when i merge the subplots all those
spots
positive for purkinje cell marker ppp1
r17
are grouped together in one super
cluster
here on the right hand side
this means that the gene expression
patterns in these three clusters
are similar does that also mean that the
tissue localization of the tissue spots
is similar
to answer that question i need to add
the tissue data
i will go back to the clustering result
drag it to the main panel
on the left hand side of the disney it's
going to be
a 2d scatter plot by default first two
genes
by alphabet are shown on the axis and
each data point each dot is a tissue
spot
with spatial transcriptomics each tissue
spot has two additional features
on top of gene expression those features
are spot coordinates
the location of the spot on the tissue
slide
i want to see the horizontal coordinate
of each spot
on the horizontal axis of my chart
let's go open the clustering result
array x is my horizontal coordinate just
drag and drop
on the horizontal axis and do the same
thing
with the vertical spot coordinate drag
and drop
on the y-axis as soon as i do that
a form starts to appear and for the
final touch
i need the image of my tissue slice i
will add it to the background
of my chart there we go scroll down
find the background card choose
and this is my microscopic image
open it here you can see it lurking
behind the
the tissue spots to get a clear picture
i will just
as before decrease
the opacity here we go histology merges
cerebellum is right over here
back to transcriptomics the question was
how do my clusters align to tissue data
to answer that question first i'm going
to
remove the legend and then open the
selection panel
i'm now going to select the clusters so
the selection
rule is going to be by clustering
results i'm not interested in all of
them
but in clusters what was it cluster
number seven
as soon as i select the cluster the
matching tissue spots are highlighted
on both charts so disney and histology
slide
let's move on cluster 9 and cluster
12. yes they are right in the cerebellum
and when we look back at the disney and
those three clusters as i said before
they're
close together and completely separated
from the bulk of the data
which basically means that the
cerebellum as a whole can be separated
from the rest of the brain
based on the gene expression data here's
a tip to switch
between the data points selected and
non-selected
there's the invert selection button now
i'm focusing on the rest of the brain
and again please note that the plots are
connected
back to the cerebellum i'm going to
collapse the panel
and i also don't need a disney let's
work
on the tissue slide i'm going to color
it by the expression levels of the same
gene
therefore drag and drop on the collar
there are tissue spots with high
expression levels of ppp
1r17 across the entire cerebellum
and if i want some quantitative
information that's easy i just
mouse over a data point
and the balloon comes up
there's the tissue spot barcode plus the
coordinates
and then at the bottom the gene
expression level
this is nice but it's practical only for
small number
of data points therefore let me show you
something more comprehensive
i want to explore the expression levels
of this gene
across the clusters
add a new plot grab the clustering
result
to the right hand side this is going to
be
another to the scatter plot
since we are talking about ppp1r17
i'm going to add it to the vertical axis
of my new chart
gene expression levels are an example of
a continuous variable but our charts
also support categorical variables
therefore i'm going to add my clusters
on the horizontal axis drag
and drop it's easier to customize
if i enlarge it therefore full screen
mode
here we go each dot is a tissue spot
let me first summarize the data per
cluster by using for instance
violence here are the controls
summary card and with one click we
transform this chart
into a violin plot we can extensively
customize it for instance
turn the points off back on
overlay on the violin bodies
spread them some more
by using the jitter
option and finally add some color for
instance
color by cluster
highest expression levels of ppp1r17
in cluster number seven a quick reminder
all the plots can be downloaded as a
high resolution image files by using the
save image icon
okay close this i don't really need
the charts anymore
i will now classify my first cell
cluster
here that was cluster number seven
and those tissue spots i will classify
as
parking g cells
save 282 spots
over here to classify the other tissue
spots
i can simply combine these steps or use
some other ones
here's a suggestion let's focus on a
different cluster
say cluster number five
and color the slide by the m by the
marker
of that cluster which is faded in heavy
chain one
so drag and drop
now we can use gene expression level
to filter the tissue spots by
that's what i'm going to do take the
gene of interest
and land on the selection card here
create a new selection rule
now a new card appears first we can see
the
expression range and there are these
blue dots
in the middle that's slider
mousing over gives me the expression
histogram
with two types of columns dark blue
columns
represent tissue spots in cluster five
the current cluster
while the other data points are
represented by the
light blue columns as i said this is a
slider
and then i can easily set my threshold
for selection
and you see as i move the slider the
spots
are being deselected or selected back
once all the tissue spots are classified
we end up with a visualization
like this one we saw it at the very
beginning
and i'm sure you will agree this looks
just like a
page from a mouse histology atlas
time to switch gears and i'm now going
to take you through
a different data set this one is based
on
excited essay real quick excite seek
is a crispr compatible version of
sightseek
the data for the demo were made publicly
available by the authors
of the original excite sync manuscript
it is a very rich methods paper which
actually consists of several multiomics
experiments
and for the purpose of this
demonstration i chose a subset
of the one on the k562 cells
the k562 cells are immortalized
human myelogenous leukemia cell line
in the current experiment the k562 cells
were infected with the crispr library
comprising guides targeting the gene
integrin beta 1
itgb1 product of which is cd29
a well-known cell surface protein
expressed by k562 cells
the cartoon at the bottom is the
blueprint of the experiment end of my
demo
first the cell hashing feature is used
to detect
and remove cell doublets
the second step is identification of
cells
which express the crispr guides and this
experiment
includes two guides single guide or
sgrnas
targeting two different regions of the
itgb1 gene
now if the crispr worked then the sgrnas
will lead to first
downregulation of the itgb1 mrna
and second downregulation of the cd29
protein
hence the goal of the final third step
and this is actually side seek
is to confirm the absence of the
targeted mrna
or the protein my question is can we
detect all those events simultaneously
on the same
cells yes we can i am now going back to
project flow to show you how
the data viewer is up with a umap
depiction
of some 2800
cells in this experiment going back to
the experiment design
please recall that the library was cell
hashed
which allows us to detect cell doublets
i'm going to start with that
on the data tab we see the annotated
counts node
and that's the one that contains all the
data for this project
click to see the attributes the one that
i need is
cells in droplet i will color the umap
by that
drag and drop
by far most cells are indeed singlets
they're in red but we also see some
doublets blue data points
and we see some unassigned cells which
are shown in gray
to focus on singlets only i'm going to
expand the selection panel add the
selection rule
cells in droplet and
select singlets only
now use the filtering tool to include
only the selected points
the data viewer is now showing only
singlets
with the doublets out of the picture i'm
ready to proceed to the next step
the second layer of information
of omics is the expression of crispr
guides
for this demo i'm going to use two
different guides targeting the same gene
the gene being targeted please permit me
to remind you is integrin beta1 it gp1
and now let's color the cells by guide
expression
again annotated counts node click
now i will use the search box and look
for the first guide itgb
1.1 drag and drop to colored
cells by the guide expression levels
let's go for red
yep this cell cluster is now
highlighted these cells express the
first guide itgb 1.1
let's add the second guide annotated
counts
search for the second guide itg b
1.2 i will just use a different color
let's color them blue here we go a
different
cell cluster comes up these blue cells
expressing itgb 1.2
okay now i'm going
to focus on crisper positive cells only
with the help of our flexible selection
tool
here it is lasso tool i will just circle
around them
as you see the tool is very very
flexible
yep the legend is now red
to blue gradient cells expressing one
guide
are in red the other guide in blue and
we also see
two cells these gray dots in the middle
which express both guides at the same
time
depending on your goal you may want to
remove them
using a combination of selection
and filter tools
at this point we know which cells
express our crispr guide which is nice
but what we really want to know is
whether our targeting works to rephrase
we need to confirm the down expression
of the targeted gene
which brings me to the side c cassay and
the third layer
of omics information if crispr worked
we should see no gene expression
therefore let's examine the expression
of
itgb1 mrna
annotate it counts itgb
here it is itgb1 add as color
i will use the third color right now the
legend
is now a triangle our crisper guides are
in blue
in red as they used to be and the
expression levels of
itgb1 mrna are in green
currently selected cells are crispr
positive
and we see that crispr positive cells do
not express
itgb1 mrna let's invert the selection
and as expected crispr negative cells
do express itgb1 mrna
for the final confirmation and the
fourth layer of omics
let's see the the protein level
annotated counts the protein is cd29
green is fine i'll stick with green
and here we go negative cells
do express cd29 protein and i will
invert back crispr negative cells
do not express cd or crispr
positive cells do not express cd29
to quickly recap cell hashing crispr
gene and protein expression all on the
same cells
let's do some closing remarks
with the help of the slidac
there is a functionality that we will
release soon the search portal
it allows you to perform searches of
either your own project database
or data from public repositories
therefore you you may have restricted
access to the lab due to the current
public health situation
but you can for instance use public data
to generate or test hypotheses
we have three trials of all our packages
and to apply for your
free trial of partak flow please
use the link on the screen finally an
announcement we regularly focus
on different aspects on of
our software and host public webinars
the next
next one is going to be on trajectory
analysis
imported flow the registration is now
open you see the registration link we
would be very happy to welcome you again
thank you so much for your attention
today thank you